[Musique]
il ne connaît pas l'anglais il parle
largo le verlan il manie l'expression
populaire avec maestria et tout un
public le comprendre après les années
difficiles où il fut magasinier
plongeurs représentant liftier tout en
continuant à gratter de la guitare le
voici aujourd'hui sur le podium des hit
parades mais c'est toujours dans la même
barak qu'il répète avec ses copains
[Musique]
courez au flipper le type est entré dans
le bar a commandé un jambon-beurre
physique s'est approché de moi je te
fais tes bottes à la baston presque
guérie
laisse béton les jeunes surtout les
jeunes des milieux urbains se
reconnaissent en connaissent leur
langage et leur préoccupation
les faits divers que chanter ils sont
tous vécu ce que chante plus ou moins
ils le ressentent bien parce que je
pense le exprimé dans leur langage
c'est ma seconde maison les bistrots
c'est le lieu de communication
[Musique]
privilégié pour les jeunes vullierens
c'est là que tout se passe qu'on c'est
là qu'on se construit le monde contre
détruit qu'on leur fait on rêve qu'on
s'exprime
comment font-ils les autres jeunes pour
s'en sortir ceux qui ne sont pas
chanteur aux champions de football
je me le demande ils font ils font les
conneries qui meublent les pages des
faits divers des journaux
il vole ibra qui s'ébattent s'ennuie six
femmes et ils vont ni strauss
[Musique]
on n'est pas là pour se faire piétiner